let's go next to our caller from the six
seven eight
area code who's calling today from six
seven eight
hey David my name is John I'm from
Atlanta big fancy show
thank you I didn't want to talk about
like my my my my thought process in this
coming election I was a practicing
supporter and I'm having kind of a hard
time switching over to giving my support
to Biden for most of the reasons and one
of the reasons that I've been thinking
about that a lot we don't talk about is
like the biggest things I've heard is
election the most important thing that
we must do to get rid of dark get rid of
Donald Trump and I agree with that
but my problem is that Joe Biden has
made it no secret that if he were to be
elected he's gonna bring back on like
that Obama Eric on third waves tourism
as a template for governance in the
White House and that sort of ideology is
what was I believe in my opinion was one
of the stars of the Trump ideology being
such an attractive regno people being
disaffected by a guy like third wave
sitter ISM so my question is what is the
point of defeating Donald Trump when
you're going to bring back the ideology
that helped give this Trump in the first
place
like what 2024 like I believe that you
should get rid of Trump Trump ISM is one
the same with the Republican Party won't
that cost another like right-wing
backlash three floors where the
Republicans even wore form a right
nationalist so a couple of the right
thing they're a couple different things
there first of all your argument is a I
believe more theoretical argument than
is relevant in terms of our decision in
November it's I don't want to discount
what you're talking about
as very important for thinking about the
future direction of the country the
future direction of the two major
parties it's important conversation to
have one thing that you're missing from
your sort of framing is that racism was
also part of what took place during
Obama's presidency that coalesced and
emboldened
some of Donald Trump's key
constituencies and I think if we're
going to really talk about what happened
during the Obama administration that led
to Trump we can't ignore that but I want
to put that aside just for a second if
if we can John what I want to say to you
is the following the theoretical
argument about Third Way sent this that
okay who do you prefer to choose the
next Supreme Court justice Trump or
Biden just and don't think don't
overthink it Byron okay when it comes to
the tax policy which candidate has a
better tax proposal if you're familiar
with them is it what we've seen Trump do
or is it what Joe Biden has proposed
proposed okay Joe Biden supports the
green new deal as a framework if not in
its full scope Trump believes climate
change is a hoax created by the Chinese
which of those positions is closer to
yours right okay so I could go on with
twenty issues so for me it's just much
simpler we have an emergency
Bernie Sanders recognizes it Noam
Chomsky recognizes it and for me the way
forward in November is not about the
effect of third way politics on it or
the future of the its we actually have a
list of twenty policy issues on which
Biden's better for me it's that simple
okay I understand I understand that that
sort of like thinking but I was more
concerned about like you know just over
time will we like all these games they
were going to making these four years of
abiding would just be like the Lakers
like I said before I just I just I can't
even though Trump may be gone I just
cannot imagine Republican Party who out
trumpism like I think Trump isn't has
replaced the kind of like Reagan era of
thought I don't think you're on and they
don't say run the Reagan style
conservatives are increasingly not what
feels like the core of the modern
Republican Party okay okay oh and just
one last thing before I got the cause of
it I live in Georgia and I'm gonna wear
like Georgian politics but our governor
can't there's going to like open up the
restrictions in the state on this Friday
yeah and if you can into the information
I've been hearing like some theories
that the reason why I can't wants to
open up
so early you know relatively like what
scientists has been saying is that
there's been a extra astronomical amount
of like unemployment claims in the state
of Georgia and we actually may run out
because in Georgia and words like
increase the income tax which of course
that you have to do a constitutional
amendment and with a
republican-controlled legislature that's
like impossible so I was thinking maybe
can I look into that and see like how
maybe that my clients will affect it I
think George is gonna be a devastating
set how you're opening up the state
before we even hit our apex so right I
don't know about the specifics in
Georgia but there is no question that
the reason that a lot of red state
governors want to reopen sooner than
later is if your business is allowed to
be open then you are going to have a
more difficult time getting PPP money
and other federal stimulus money if your
business is open you are going to be
taken off of the unemployment rolls and
that is that there's no doubt that that
is playing a role in red state governors
wanting to open sooner than later
absolutely okay but thank you David
all right appreciate the call thank you
so much really great to hear from you